I have great confidence in my
intelligence people but I will tell you
that President Putin was extremely
strong and powerful in his denial today
what I see
Russia as a state has never interfered
with the internal affairs of the United
States let alone its elections
sir this this is the indictment it shows
I have 12 names here it talks about
specific units of the GRU russian
military intelligence is the GRU not
part of the russian state a fascinating
and surreal summit and news conference
and then a fascinating interview with
the russian president let's bring in our
panel Molly Hemingway senior editor at
The Federalist moralized a national
political correspondent of National
Public Radio and Chris steinwald his
politics editor here at Fox News Molly
your take on all of it it's been a crazy
day and a lot of people here in DC are
absolutely freaking out about President
Trump declining to have a strong
condemnation of Russia they're saying
this is treasonous that he's a traitor a
strong condemnation of Russia for their
election meddling they're saying he's a
traitor he needs to be removed from
office I think a lot of the people who
support him say I don't see what the big
deal is there's not much you can do in
this kind of environment but it seems
like Donald Trump of all people should
have been able to split this baby and
that you can point out that our
intelligence agencies have come to this
conclusion and it's not just Bob Moeller
in fact that Bob Moeller indictment
reads a lot like the report that came
out of the house permanent Select
Committee on Intelligence led by Devon
Nunez it's also Dan Coates these are
people this is a very broad bipartisan
issue so you can stand behind that and
and also make the point that he's
declining to admit guilt you know you're
referencing that John Brennan former CIA
director who put out that tweet about
treasonous but they're also Trump
supporters like the former House Speaker
Newt Gingrich who tweeted out a little
while ago President Trump must clarify
his statements on in Helsinki on our
intelligence system and Putin it is the
most serious mistake of his presidency
and must be corrected immediately that
from Newt Gingrich yeah and you had
statements from Paul Ryan you had
statements from Mitch McConnell you had
people like bob corker of
people who are not running again who are
free being a flake or free to be more
critical but now I haven't seen anyone
rushing to the president's defense and
saying what he did in Helsinki was good
and held up the interests of the United
States okay well I want to say something
about that interview which was amazing
yes Vladimir Putin even though of course
he denies interfering in our elections
went on in granular detail to describe
why releasing the emails hacked from the
DNC was something like a public service
certainly didn't the public have a right
to know how the Democrats were
manipulating their primary process in
favor of Bernie Sanders well we didn't
do we didn't do it that I thought was
pretty amazing I think that he doesn't
care if people think he did it as a
matter of fact I thought he was boasting
a little bit he didn't have that look
about the smirk kind of and mmm he
probably quite intentionally dovetails
his critique there with the president's
argument and the arguments that the
president's supporters make and they
overlap and I am sure that for there's a
about 25 percent in the most recent Pew
poll about 25 percent of Republicans
have a favorable view of Vladimir Putin
and think he's alright and for that
quarter of the Republican Party order
and growing of the Republican Party they
probably agree with them that say well
you know what if you hacked her at least
we found out in Hillary's not president
so I think that that's that's not going
nowhere
so the first time that President Trump
will speak out after all of this and the
reaction to it will be on sean hannity
show tonight 9:00 p.m. eastern time
here's a little taste of that 90% of the
nuclear power in the world between these
two nations and we've had a phony witch
hunt deal drive us apart this is the
biggest wedge this was the thing it's
the thing that he told me when he went
in he said what a shame he felt it was
very hard for me to make a deal because
of you know all of this nonsense talking
about Putin and the investigation the
Muller investigation well but it's so
interesting to watch here is that for a
year and a half we have had the media in
the intelligence community completely
conflate the issue of Russian meddling
with this theory of treasonous collusion
to steal an election
that belonged to Hillary Clinton that
has caused real damage to the Trump
administration it caused damage before
he was inaugurated it completely
sidelined his Attorney General so that
the Department of Justice is completely
not run by it by one of his by by his
Attorney General and it caused so many
problems and yet now people are trying
to pretend like they didn't conflate
those two issues and now they're trying
to separate them it's it's true that
Donald Trump has trouble separating
those two issues but he has trouble
because he's been victimized for a year
and a half by people who are unable to
separate those it will be interesting to
see what points were put on the board or
whether this is the start of just more
talks because it's the the blow up is
quite some somebody's gonna have to quit